coming to columbia was a great
experience in just opening my eyes to
different people in different parts of
the world columbia was a home away from
home some of my happiest days are still
columbia days feeling that the spirit is
still here Jacqueline Bello College of
Physicians and Surgeons 1980 where this
garden in particular has a lot of
meaning for me i was born in the
harkness pavilion and i graduated in
this garden from the College of
Physicians and Surgeons in 1980 my class
was a class of unity so much so that 10
people in my class married 10 other
people in my class the appreciation that
kicks in when
and you realize that you've gotten it
right and you realize that there is a
difference between your education and
what others in medicine know make it
easy to come full circle and to come
back and to want to give and to want to
stay connected I began very modestly by
giving my time giving my energy on
giving back leadership and then
gradually I had the opportunity to
establish an award named for my father
who's also a P&S grad so that on the
occasion of his 50th anniversary we
instituted an award to be given a
graduation and this award is given for
listening what thrilled me about the
timing of the medal is that it was given
on the occasion of his 60th anniversary
or the 10th year of that award being
established i wish i could give many
more awards
in greater amounts and forever mr.
president we are so proud of our alumni
Caterina auto Bernstein Columbia is sort
of the essence and the very best of what
New York has to offer is a very
international school which for me as
European was very important it really
became a home for me columbia and
especially the faculty at columbia
teaches you to think outside box I met
with school they don't became the Dean
of the film score as my writing
professor and we hated each other and
then I took a year absence i was hired
to some location scouting for somebody
in 89 in Berlin when the wall came down
and I came back and I had missed my spot
for a thesis advisor and my thesis
advisor was designated to me and it was
Lewis Cole and I thought oh god and out
of that grew probably one of the closest
friendships I've ever had with a
professor the deans council is is really
a think tank and we try to develop
concepts for the police full of the arts
and its future the in long-term plan is
to really eight people in looking into
the after and help them to also plan for
different careers I think one needs to
explore is in editing
in cinematography and not just be
limited to screen writing and directing
free thinking and the courage to go
forward and take a risk I think needs to
be supported George Stern Columbia
College 1958 engineering 1959 Columbia
always had deep meaning to me I wear my
comedy arang and I wanted for 50 years
of one actually longer than my wedding
band they've got engaged when I was a
junior here at the engineering school
and got married about six months after
graduation from the engineering school
this was the building that was the
school of engineering in the 1950s they
subsequently of course built mud and
then beyond that the book Shapiro and
now they're building a new research
center I mean you come back after 50
years and you're three buildings behind
you never forget this is where it
started this is where you went from
being a high school student to being
part of a university in a world started
out in the very first year by
volunteering to interview at high
schools I found letters from the Alumni
Office in 1960 saying how gratefully
were that I would go to some of these
very small towns in Maryland West
Virginia in Ohio we established a
committee structure to look at specific
problems that were the school was facing
and we can establish that the
engineering council was not just to hear
what was going on to school but was
really to be a counselor to the Dean
that's what I'm proud of being in
detroit's you get lost from all of
Columbia don't think
anybody who ever think of you and
Columbia would think of me I found most
rewarding and gratifying to walk out
from low library 35,000 people which
again it's an astonishing experience
you